This morning, frustration is on the rise at airports across the country.
I just don't understand how this is okay.
With more than fifteen hundred flights canceled this weekend,...
...and at least thirteen thousand delays from coast to coast.
Hopefully, it doesn't get canceled again...
...because I definitely need to get home and get stuff done.
Nasty storms setting off a cascade of chaos for travelers.
It's just really draining and frustrating.
American and Southwest Airlines blaming summertime thunderstorms...
...and weather-related challenges for the disruptions.
But it's been a rocky summer for airlines dealing with crew and pilot shortages,...
...reduced flight schedules, and a record surge in travelers.
There aren't a lot of pilots sitting in reserve.
There aren't a lot of planes sitting in reserve or crew or staff.
And so when there's one cancellation,...
...there's very little buffer or slack in the system.